so let's get into it now
with a former house speaker newton
gingrich now a fox news political
analyst and author of the brand new book
beyond biden rebuilding the america we
love that title is right on time and
we'll get to that in a moment
yeah because this is part of it right
it's so great to have you in focus today
out of the breaking news your top line
thoughts with what senator paul is
trying to get to there well i think in
any
reasonable society
felt she would be gone
he's violated his own rules he wrote a
paper on this back about
2012
talking about dangerous research and
what standards ought to be set and
admitting that in the end this was more
than a scientific question because
dangerous research was a threat to the
whole society
i've known fauci since he did brilliant
work on hiv aids in the 1980s and i'm
sad to say it but i think he now is
destructive i think he is dishonest
i think he is trying to save his
reputation and he's doing so at very
substantial risk to lives around the
planet and
it's very unfortunate uh and they go
through this same sound conversation
every time
and and and falchi
hides behind word games
uh
the fact is that
they were running experiments the very
notion that he trusted the chinese
when you know that the chinese
dictatorship uh was literally locking up
doctors who didn't do what it told them
to and you go back and look at the
origins of this the effort by the
chinese dictatorship to cover it up for
the first two two or three months um
the fact that fauci could say i trust
them
by itself is an indictment of naivete
you know it's interesting because you go
back to the words the same way that
senator rand paul does he's like are you
trying to redefine now for
all of us like we're children and we
don't have a webster's i guess or the
internet
speaker uh the definition of gain of
function which is not a new science
so you don't have to spend all that
taxpayer money to figure out what it is
well and you have to ask yourself the
question
given the degree to which china is still
clearly a totalitarian society in which
the dictator xi
defines reality
why would the u.s taxpayers be funding
research in a chinese laboratory now the
answer is well
south asia and particularly south china
is a major center of these kind of
diseases well i would much rather have
the bats brought to the u.s
or to taiwan or to japan or to singapore
but the idea that we're going to send
money to wuhan
in order for chinese scientists under
the control of the chinese secret police
that we're then going to trust not not
have people there by the way when they
did break out they wouldn't let us come
in right so they wouldn't even let us
look at the research we were paying for
well they had scientists in that lab who
were getting sick and dying right i mean
we didn't know that at the time we
didn't find that out until later but
there was a lot happening but found she
behaves as though all of this is is not
reality
uh so it's as though there's not a
chinese dictatorship it's as though
scientists didn't die
and and it's unfortunate because he is
probably the most prominent spokesperson
on on these kind of diseases in the
world and the fact that he's now
completely defending his reputation at
the cost of the people not just in the
united states but worldwide is really
tragic and someday historians will write
about it you know you lay it out with
your experience having known him and
also knowing so much about our enemy
china and let's just call it what it is
because a friend would not have kept us
out like that they would have partnered
with us on on finding a vaccine on doing
the right thing in the beginning
but it's it's almost like fauci is
acting as though and we know it's true
he he doesn't have to say much because
it's all unknowable now
we can't get in and the chinese have
done whatever they're going to the
chinese government forgive me have done
whatever it's going to do
and and it might be impossible to get
all of those answers
in a more contemporaneous way which
would lead you to be a little more
cautious and maybe a little more
you know we did i did a podcast with
with dr fauci in february of 2020 when
this was just starting
and it's really interesting to go back
and listen to it now because in february
he was pretty passive this is probably
not going to be a pandemic it's probably
not going to be a crisis but i think and
that's code for he was wrong
i mean it's in his own words it's not me
it's his voice i want to get to your new
book
uh beyond biden rebuilding the america
we love it's available now online or in
a real live bookstore just walk right in
i'm still shopping old school with my
kids for books tell us about this one
well i deliberately decided not to write
an anti-biden book on the grounds that
biden would be sufficiently anti himself
that that that's not an issue oh that's
interesting what we wanted to do was say
this is going to be a mess
we have really big things and i think by
the way the yunkan his campaign really
fits almost exactly what beyond biden
talks about because he talked about
fixing the schools he talked about
creating jobs he talked about doing
things to bring down crime so he was
talking in the real world about real
change and that's what i think we need
to recognize if we don't go through
profound modernization
we are not going to be competitive with
china and we are going to lose we think
in our lifetime oh i don't think biden
has a clue i mean i i think
i think joe biden is a nice pleasant guy
who is totally out of touch with reality
surrounded by left-wing staffers who
live in a fantasy world
i always tell people to understand their
attitude towards threats whether it's
terrorism or it's china imagine that
they saw the lion king and thought it
was a documentary and they actually
believe lions and zebras dance and sing
together wow you know i mean that's how
they behave they don't understand we're
in a life and death struggle with a
chinese dictatorship which would like to
dominate our society which has
hundreds if not thousands of agents in
our society which has a methodical
strategy of both stealing our
intellectual property and bribing our
scientists and lying to us
at a deadly at the start of a deadly
pandemic there's just so much of it i
don't know when you started to think
about this but it's only been 10 months
no right after right after the election
we said that's amazing well
you could predict what
the great trial the great tragedy is
that big government socialism doesn't
work it didn't work in zimbabwe it
doesn't work in venezuela irrespective
of
and so i was willing to once you knew
who was going to dominate
and it was clear that biden
he gave a very nice inaugural address
about coming together etc and the same
day he signed a whole series of
executive orders dismantling what trump
had done so you look at what he's doing
behind the speech and i just i knew by
then what they were going to try to do
would be a disaster
and now we can read about your
perspective in terms of actions what do
we do to fix the country once we win
could you start with inflation anyway we
could do a whole hour together and i'm
so glad you were here congratulations on
the news great to be back in the studio
yes and i'll see you soon i hope good
all right hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now